heja einfache aber dass flughafen meine
damen und herren ihre sechs bereichen
seite eingeblendet es geht heute um
wörth ja danke schön heute wenn dieses
video hier rauskommen ist der dreißigste
elfte das heißt sie morgen in einem tag
ist der erste zwölfter und morgen kommt
um 15 uhr eine neue kollektion in den
super minister für das heutige videos
dazu da euch einen kurzen überblick über
den fünf produkte zu geben und auch am
ende noch kurz den titel zu erklären
ja ich würde aber sagen gefangen direkt
mit dem ersten produkt das ist nämlich
das produkt was ich hier an habe das ist
ein grauer smileys über tag hier
der schnitt ist so der oberst also für
den winter so dass man ein bisschen
chillen und so hier bei mir immer
wichtig weil ich gerne diesen etwas
stabileren style trage in allen
produkten xl die ich euch jetzt gleich
zeigen werde aber ja genau das ist mein
absolutes bin ich ganz ehrlich
lieblingsprodukt von der neuen sachen
die wir im shop kommen also mir selbst
aufgefallen dass ich dieses produkt
selber am meisten tragen es ist ein
simpler graues wetter mit einem mit sehr
hochwertigen 100% baumwollstoffe made in
italy selbstverständlich also qualität
steht bei uns ganz oben und auf der
linken brust ist ein smiley reingesteckt
mit so ein bisschen pastellfarben zu
hellen pastellfarben runter tropfen
da kommen wir auch nun direkt zu den
produkten was sage ich mal diesmal das
neue special produkt sein wird also
jedes mal wenn ich neue klamotten
rausbringe kommt ihr ein produkt was es
so im shop bisher noch nicht gab dieses
jahr ist das einlud rust leder etui
beziehungsweise schulen mäppchen habt
ihr sagt der tui oder schulmädchen
schule sagt immer federmäppchen box hat
man immer etwas gesagt ist ja auch egal
auf jeden fall ist es ein kunstleder
mädchen also nicht echtes leder
eine luke cage vorne drauf das war es
einfach wichtig dass es ja so ein
bisschen so eine tiefe hat und nicht
einfach drauf gesprintet ist und was mir
auch wichtig war ganz einfach das ist
einen dreieckigen sondern dreieckige
form hat weil ich hasse diese mädchen
die rund sind und dann fallen die wahl
und dann kommen alle sachen raus sondern
dass hier acht war sie eine ebene fläche
und den stifter drin sind zehn jahre
radiergummi füller textmarker cetera
dann bleibt es auf jeden fall stehen das
hier meine damen und herren wir design
der wort mit den shop kombiniert das ist
eine 100% baumwolle wo die hellblau mit
einem reverse meine hier darauf mit so
einem kleinen smiley den haben wir im
siebdruckverfahren drauf gucken lassen
die kapuze ist mehr oder weniger zwei
jahren damit ich ein bisschen ich sag
mal voller bier und was auch besonders
ist sind diese kordeln das sind nämlich
keine normalen kordeln sondern wirklich
wäre der dicke komplett baumwolle
dunkelblaue weiß gestreiften zum pinsel
dran der stoff wege haben uns extra
gedacht okay ich mache mir den stoff ein
bisschen dünner
damit man denen gut die sage es mal
nicht nur jetzt im winter an haben kann
wenn es kalt ist sondern wirklich auch
irgendwie doch im frühjahr oder auch ist
ja auch eine sehr sommerliche farbe sage
ich mal wenn ihr allerdings etwas haben
möchte etwas extra den weichsten stock
hat den wir je hatten wir uns im shop
und wenn ihr wirklich was für ein winter
haben wollte also wirklich richtig warm
hält dann haben wir hier
diesen christmas wetter für euch extra
nicht so komplett durchgezogen gedruckt
sondern mit dem siebdruckverfahren nur
so abwechseln sagt man so stix rauf
gemacht wer sollte ich diese
siebdruckverfahren so aus als wäre das
nicht mal so geregnet dave und ich weiß
leider nicht was heißt er genau begriffe
ist allerdings sollten ganze waren das
wetter rein nur mit den print herz so
ein wenig tourismus sie seien also auch
100% baumwolle und wirklich leute ich
glaube das sieht man schon dass es jetzt
laut six beweisen dürfen stoffe der
börse flaut schicke weiße stoff den er
je an haben werdet also dieser wird auf
jeden fall auf morgen neu in den shop
kommen und kommen nun allerdings schon
zum letzten produkt beziehungsweise zum
fünften der fünf produkte die morgen den
shop kommen werden
das ist nämlich ein t shirt
ja denn im winter trägt man ja nicht nur
rudi ist ein normales schwarzes t shirt
mit einer luxushotel applikation heißes
glaube das sieht man schon das ist hier
nicht irgendwie drauf printed nicht
gesteckt das ist wirklich so ein
handtuch stoff da drauf und dann ist da
so ein college look schriftzug drauf
auch verständlich 100 prozent baumwolle
wir haben eine grammaturen von 170 gramm
pro quadratmeter und natürlich alles
made in italy qualität steht aber uns
wirklich ganz grobe und nun freunde
was hat es mit dem titel auf sich ja ihr
seht schon hier geht es mit der hatte
was anschauen mensch hat in wörth von
hier an
die usa lasten lieber noch mal schauen
wenn das nochmal justin bieber
tatsächlich auch also wirklich viele
deutsche und personen des öffentlichen
lebens khalid beispielsweise hatte auch
etwas an wurden von paparazzis dabei
entdeckt wie sie meine merge getragen
haben wie sie es gerockt haben in los
angeles in london über all die bilder
sind komplett fake die habe ich da
in photoshop bearbeitet weil ich mir
dachte okay das ist ganz lustig ich habe
in den letzten tagen meine instagram
story gehauen und so ein bisschen sagt
mal promo zu machen für den zwölften
morgen um 15 uhr kommen die neuen sachen
in den shops ist er minister von de
[Musik]
tatsächlich einige nachfragen von wegen
wieder treten schon wendet von luca
machte er nicht
leider gehen heute auf ein promo zwecken
reise tut mir leid ich da einige von
euch leider verwehrt habe einen justin
bieber fan page war auch ein bisschen
abgefuckt darüber machen was kann ich
sagen freunde es kommt 59 produkte den
shop ein schulmädchen 22.30 uhr und ein
t shirt im morgen am ersten 12 10 15 uhr
kommen die sachen online und zu den
ersten 2000 bestellungen wird es zum
ersten mal eine signierte autogrammkarte
geben bisher hatte ich jedesmal smileys
dicker signiert jedoch jetzt morgens zum
aller ersten mal wirklich
autogrammkarten mit mir wo ich dass luca
schultern habe eine unterstützung auf
der rückseite luke haben eine shop.de
können statt punkten so eine
autogrammkarte werdet ihr erhalten wenn
wir unter den ersten 2000 2100 stellen
seit dem morgen ab 15 uhr und zeigt sich
auch einige jetzt wieder fragen wendet
der shop down seien höchstwahrscheinlich
dadurch dass ich wirklich nicht
irgendwie alle zwei drei wochen einen
teil raus bringen sondern nur ein
zweimal im jahr eine größere kollektion
mit vier bis sieben sachen hätten
natürlich wieder der shop gut besucht
sein und das freut mich auch und ich
spreche da euren support allerdings wird
ja schon wahrscheinlich auch morgen 15
uhr erstmal wieder da heute bewahrt
ich habe wirklich zum ersten mal nicht
1000 autogrammkarten mit ziemlicher
trainiert sondern 2000 ich habe extra
schon so ein bisschen vorsorge betrieben
und keines der produkte ist limitiert
also wenn ihr auch morgen oder
übermorgen oder drei tagen gestellt
bekommt ihr immer noch ein produkt vor
weihnachten geliefert also macht euch
keine sorgen falls der shop dahin wie
down sein sollte überhaupt kein ding
gestellt einfach ein bisschen später den
weg zurück in die liebsten de luca des
körpers maul und was ich sagen möchte
ich habe letztens einen kommentar unter
einer fanpage von mir gesehen von wegen
wie du hast keinen schmerz von luca du
bist ja gar kein richtiger fan es soll
wirklich in diesem video nicht so
rüberkommen von wegen hague auf meine
sachen und dann seid ihr ein größerer
teil der luchs nur oder irgendwie sowas
das soll ganz einfach so sein dass ich
euch einfach zeigen mir macht es spaß
sachen design
mir macht es spaß den von ihm des
zusammenzuarbeiten seit mittlerweile
mehr als drei jahren und deswegen habe
ich die sachen in meinem shop und wenn
ihr euch was kaufen möchte dann mit riis
hätte ich das total und mich freut es
sehr weil ich einfach sehr dass euch die
sachen gefallen
aber wenn ihr nichts kaufen möchte seid
ihr natürlich nicht weniger werden sagt
jetzt mal oder nicht weniger teil meiner
community also ich möchte euch um gottes
willen überhaupt nicht zwingen
irgendetwas zu kaufen es liegt bei euch
die entscheidungen nur bei euch oder
vielleicht auch euren eltern ob wir
heute morgen etwas kauft auf euch
überhaupt etwas kauft das liegt komplett
bei euch die entscheidung und möchte
euch dazu nichts drängen also wenn ihr
das feiert dann würde ich mich natürlich
sehr freuen aber wenn ich eure
entscheidung und es ist euer geschmack
und geschmäcker genau sondern das ist
vollkommen in ordnung dort allerdings
nicht mehr lange
was freunde ab morgen das auf dem ersten
12 und 15 uhr gibt es diese fünf neue
sachen im shop einige alte sachen werden
rausgenommen damit platz schaffen für
den job und er nicht auf einen nähten
platzt irgendwann will ich dass ich an
der stelle jetzt auch beenden
[Musik]